in the last video we looked at this rc
circuit and we gave it a step input with
this step source a step from v naught up
to v s with a sharp change
right here at t equals zero and we sort
of took an intuitive guess at what this
voltage looks like here
what's v of t
and in this video we're going to develop
a precise expression for what happens
here to this voltage across the
capacitor and as we said this is a very
very common circuit there's millions and
millions of these types of circuits
inside every computer so it really pays
to understand this one quite well
because this is a function of time
because we have a function of time here
this is going to end up needing
techniques from calculus to to really
figure out properly
so this is going to be a place where our
calculus skills are really necessary
and i'm also going to assume that you've
listened to the video on rc natural
response where we worked out the
expression for the natural response when
there was no voltage here when this was
zero
the natural response looks like
v equals
v naught
e to the minus t over
rc and there's a video on khan academy
about natural response and there's also
an article you can you can review too
so let's get back here let's analyze
this formally and one of the things we
can do is uh well first thing we always
do is we always label the con the
quantities that we want in here and i'll
put there's the current and here we'll
call this voltage
of r
and if i've used a lowercase letter v
that or i that means the quantity is
changing with time and if i use a big a
capital letter v here that means that
those values don't change with time so
that's my notation
and when we analyze the circuit a good
thing to do is just to look at what are
the component equations for this thing
so
let's talk about ohm's law for this
resistor here we know that vr
equals i times r
or another way we can write that is i
equals
vr
over r
so the other expression i can write for
the capacitor is the capacitor iv
equation which is i
equals c
dv
dt
and this means this means the slope of
the voltage or the rate of change of the
voltage
times c is equal to the current
all right
so far so good i have one eye there's
actually only one i in this circuit so
this i here is equal to this one here
that's a good relationship for us to
know
and we also have two different v
variables we have regular v that's
across the capacitor
and we have v sub r
so let me see if i can write v sub r in
terms of v
and one thing i can tell from this
circuit
this point right here
this is v s
this is vc
so i can write
vr
equals vs
minus vc
right that's going to be useful all
right so now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to set these two eyes equal to
each other and at the same time i'll
plug in
this expression vs minus vc
for vr up here it'll go in right here
so we can write
c
dv
dt
equals
1 over r
times
vr vr is
vs
minus vc
so i shouldn't write vc i'll just write
v
we'll take that out there because we
don't need that subscript
and multiply through by 1 over r and on
we get
c dv
dt
equals 1 over r
vs
minus
1 over r
v
and we'll get
c
dv dt
minus 1 over r
times v
equals
v s
all right so now we have this is our
differential equation it's a
differential equation because it has
derivatives in it
and this is in particular this is called
a non-homogeneous
ordinary differential equation
it's ordinary because there's the first
derivative the first derivative has a
power one here that's the ordinary it's
a differential equation because it has a
derivative and it's called
non-homogeneous
because this side over here that because
this is not
v or a derivative of v
so this this equation is sort of mixed
up it's non-homogeneous
when we did the natural response
analysis
this term right here was zero
in the uh in that equation and so we
were able to solve this rapidly
so we're going to develop a new strategy
here for for solving this kind of
equation this this kind of
non-homogeneous ode
so this equation is a little tricky to
solve because this is not zero over here
we have a mixture of things going on
here this side of the equation
represents the forcing function this is
what the circuit is being driven to
by that step response input voltage
source and then this side here we're
going to get tied up with the initial
conditions that that capacitor has so
there's sort of a two things going on
here that make this a little more
complicated than usual to solve and so
what our strategy is we take on a
strategy here
we break the problem down into two
pieces this is always what engineers do
when you're faced with something that is
a little complicated is you try to break
it into bits and pieces so what we're
going to do is we're going to our
strategy is to figure out
what we call the natural response
we're going to figure out something
called
the forced response
and then we're going to add those
together with a plus sign
and that's going to be equal to what we
call the total response so this is what
the circuit really does
all right so we've got two new words
here one's the forced response and one's
the total response and if we remember
remember before the natural response was
what the circuit did when when nothing
was forcing it we just put in some
initial energy some charge and let the
circuit sort of sag toward wherever it
was going that's the natural response
the force response is going to be
what the input source forces the circuit
to do and when we take those two things
and add them together we'll get what the
circuit is going to do all together
and this is a this is a another another
good application of superposition
we're going to take two things that the
circuit does and analyze them separately
and then add them together
superimpose them to get the total
response
so the way we do this the strategy is
for the natural response
basically we take for the initial
conditions
that's the charge on the capacitor we'll
take whatever we get we'll take the
initial q
and the initial vw the v v naught
and when we look at the inputs
we'll set the inputs to zero
so that's how we analyze that's the
conditions for the natural response and
when we take the forced response
we do the opposite what we do is we set
the initial conditions to zero
simplify the circuit down and we use the
inputs that are actually applied in this
case
it was v of s
and then to get the total response
we add those together with a plus sign
so then
for the total response
you get
you get the initial conditions which is
q
and v naught and you get vs all together
so that's our strategy and by
turning it into two simpler problems
basically we make this differential
equation a little bit simpler to solve
two times than trying to solve it all
together at once
we'll stop here now and in the next
video we'll follow through on the
strategy of combining the forced
response with the natural response